is Sanaa Lathan the mystery actress who
bit Beyonce donald glover rips Marvel
with a mock Deadpool script plus 20
years of Dawson's Creek and et was on
the Capeside set looks like we may have
uncovered the identity of Beyonce's
biter no it's not Sarah Michelle Gellar
who attempted to throw off our
investigation so who is the celebrity
Chomper who took a bite abhi two sources
tell ET the biter was Sanaa Lathan
[Music]
one source doesn't believe it was
malicious or meant to be mean but it
caught Beyonce completely off-guard and
B didn't like it we're also told the
fight was playful which is interesting
because if you recall Sanaa denies she
was the culprit on Twitter but she did
add quote if I did it would have been a
love bite you know they say hindsight is
20/20 and I foolishly believed so nas
denial but in retrospect the evidence
stacks up Sanaa did film herself at
jay-z's concert on the night in question
with Cruz the son of her rumoured ex
French Montana and Tiffany Haddish
reportedly once hinted the bike gate
culprit was someone who dated French
Montana now Tiffany never ID'd the celeb
fighter but told GQ which was quote I
said to Beyonce did she really bite you
she was like yeah she not like that all
the time so it had to be a party guest
Beyonce's known for a while right well
wouldn't you know here's to not and be
hanging out almost 10 years ago et has
reached out to sonam's rep for comment
so I wouldn't go as far as to say the
case is officially closed but damn this
is a strong lead and our sources aren't
the only ones naming Sanaa in fact
Donald Glover directly calls out the
incident in a hilarious Deadpool script
on Twitter this morning it's not late
than bit Beyonce space wait oh thank god
it was Jennifer Lawrence I already hate
her it's fine
now the 15 page mock script is riddled
with recent headlines the beyonce biter
being just one of them but Donald I know
y'all working together on the Lion King
so blink twice if you'll know something
now it appears Glover wrote this script
last night to prove he wasn't too busy
to work on the show after it was
announced Donald his brother Steven and
FX would no longer be attached to
Deadpool the animated series the Atlanta
star tweeted a series of pages from his
could have been finale episode and the
man took some shots at Marvel the jabs
included this line as Deadpool talks to
the world's last male northern white
rhino named Sudan quote it just feels
like everyone wants something different
but no one wants to do anything
different to get it doesn't Marvel have
enough feel-good
already shows everyone supports but
doesn't watch I mean I think our show
would have been funny I just wanted a
place to be honest and I guess that
place is freeform on Saturday FX said in
a statement the network Donald and
Stephen Glover agreed to part ways with
Marvel TV on the animated series due to
creative differences ah that's right out
of the Hollywood breakup text book well
the same can't be said for the cast of
Dawson's Creek they stayed on for six
season until the show ended and now
they're together again for one epic
reunion james van der beek Katie Holmes
Michelle Williams and Joshua Jackson all
got together for the first time since
the 2003 finale for this aw cover shoot
in honor of the show's 20th anniversary
now it's hard to believe it's big 20
years since Dawson's Creek debuted et of
course was with the crew from Capeside
long before the show put them on the map
[Music]
it is a little racing we do push the
envelope a lot just about every episode
every scene we deal with real issues you
can't you can't deny the fact that 15
year olds are thinking about and talking
about sex
thank you the Virgin you got an alien
which is red no wasted moment it was I
mean greater man would be nailing right
now I mean yeah it's fine Josh I won't
go there I won't tell about Josh's
tendency to moon yeah he wants people to
get a good look at that but his I played
Joey Potter no my grams warned me about
you she says you're severely troubled
well no offense but your grams is
correct and she's you know she's kind of
reserved and quiet when it comes to lots
of people yet she speaks her mind when
she's with Dawson and Pacey and Jen so I
can relate to that I have a lot of fun
playing hey this morning we walked in
here and started shooting and the first
thing we saw was you and the and and
James rolling around on the whole
morning I know some perks and just
kidding not a bad gig at all young Katie
Holmes were you guys big fans of
Dawson's Creek how do you feel about
seeing them all together like this also
let me know what you think about Sanaa
possibly being the one to bite Beyonce I
say Oh Elsa not it's a lot to take in I
know so just we'll get through this
together thanks for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
where's my hot tea